los líderes de 11 países reunidos en
Brasilia la capital de Brasil con un
objetivo reafianzar la unidad de
Sudamérica una propuesta del presidente
de izquierdas Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
mientras estemos divididos no haremos de
Sudamérica un continente desarrollado
con todo su potencial
la integración debe ser el objetivo
permanente de todos nosotros tenemos que
plantar raíces fuertes para las futuras
generaciones
pero esta no es una tarea sencilla ya
que hay algunas reticencias
especialmente en turno a una figura la
de presidente de Venezuela Nicolás
maduro y es que actualmente hay una
Clara división entre los países
sudamericanos respecto a la reaparición
de maduro en la Esfera internacional
mientras que algunos como Brasil
Argentina o Colombia están a favor de su
reintegración otros como chile o Uruguay
no lo ven con tan buenos ojos
en el sentido en que la situación de
Derechos Humanos en Venezuela era una
construcción narrativa
no es una construcción narrativa es una
realidad es seria sorprendido
cuando se habló de lo que sucede en
Venezuela es una narrativa lo peor que
podemos hacer es tapar el sol con un
dedo
pongámosle el nombre que tiene y
ayudemos pero a pesar de las divisiones
se espera que en este primer encuentro
desde 2014 Las Naciones suramericanas
dialoguen sobre un nuevo mecanismo de
integración regional inspirado en la
antigua unasur ideada por Lula y el
expresidente Hugo Chávez en 2008 pero
que quedó desmantelada con el auge de
los presidentes conservadores en la
región